>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS,
THANK YOU.
FOR REACTION FROM TODAY'S VOTE
ON THE PATH AHEAD, JOIN THEM
ENOUGH FROM ATLANTA, LIKE A
MEMBER THE COMMITTEE,
DOUG COLLINS.
THANK YOU CONGRESSMAN FOR BEING
HERE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS DAY AND
WHAT THE FALLOUT IS?
>> AS I WAS FLYING BACK TO
ATLANTA IT WAS A SOBERING
THOUGHT BECAUSE WHAT I SAID
EARLIER BEGAN TO HIT.
A DARK CLOUD HAS FALLEN UPON THE
HOUSE AND IT'S NOT A CLOUD OF
SOMETHING WE HAVE NOT KNOWN
ABOUT.
IT'S SOMETHING THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE TALKED ABOUT FOR WELL OVER
TWO YEARS AND ALMOST THREE YEARS
SINCE DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED.
WHAT I DID TODAY WAS GOING TO
THE FLOOR OF THE HOUSE AND
SHREDDED OUR PROCEDURES AND
RULES AND LIED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT SAYING THEY WANT TO
BE FAIR.
HOW IS IT FAIR WHAT THEY DID
TODAY WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE THEIR SHAM BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS, HAVE A COUPLE OF
OPEN HEARINGS, BUT NO IMPARTS.
IF IT'S AN INQUIRY, HAVING NO
INPUT FROM THE ADMINISTRATION OR
ANY LAWYERS OR ANYONE ELSE.
REALLY, IT'S A SAD STATE OF
AFFAIRS AND THEY WILL HAVE TO
ANSWER FOR THAT ONE DAY.
>> Bret: THERE HAS BEEN
REPUBLICANS BEHIND HIS CLOSED
DOORS AS YOU KNOW.
THEY'VE BEEN REDIRECTING, ASKING
QUESTIONS, WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
TRANSCRIPTS OF THAT BUT THEY BED
IN THE ROOMS.
NOW YOU'RE HEADING INTO THIS
PUBLIC HEARING TIME FRAME.
AREN'T YOU GOING TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO IN FRONT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE MAKE THE CASE
BITE REDIRECTING?
>> WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
CHANCE AND IT'S INTERESTING, YOU
TALKED ABOUT NOT SAYING THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE, DULY
ELECTED FROM THE STATE OF
GEORGIA UNDER RULE BOOKS AS I
CAN HAVE ACCESS TO ANY OF THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS THAT I WANT AS LONG
AS I ASKED TO THE RELEVANT
COMMITTEE CHAIRS.
I TRIED TO DO THAT.
THAT RULE HAS NOT BEEN REPLACED
AND YET THEY WILL NOT LET ME AS
A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE TO THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO THIS,
ADAM SCHIFF AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ARE LEAKING OUT
ONLY THE PARTS THEY WANT TO LEAK
OUT AND THREATENING REPUBLICANS
NOT TO LEAK OUT ANYTHING.
THIS IS A ONE-SIDED EVENT.
THIS IS WHAT I MEAN BY THE FACT
THAT THE DEMOCRATS OR SHREDDING
THE PROCESSES OF OUR HOUSE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT ALLOWING THE
MINORITY TO HAVE ANY POSSIBILITY
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES TO
YOU THE THING THEY'RE WORKING
ON.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
BETTER.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION, YOU OUGHT TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT.
>> Bret: HERE'S WHAT DEMOCRATS
ARE SAYING.
YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
PROCESS.
YOU BEEN DEMANDING A VOTE ON THE
INQUIRY OF IMPEACHMENT AND THEY
DID THE VOTE TODAY.
THEY'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
PUBLIC HEARINGS ON THEIR CALLING
HER BLUFF AND NOW IT'S ABOUT THE
SUBSTANCE.
IF YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE SUBSTANCE?
>> VERY MUCH SO.
AT THIS AS CALLING OUR BLUFF
THAT MAYBE THEY DIDN'T HEAR WHAT
WERE ASKING FOR.
WERE ASKING FOR THE VERY SAME
THING.
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS.
GOOD PROCESS LEADS TO GOOD
SUBSTANCE.
UNLESS YOU ALREADY HAVE YOUR
MIND MADE UP ABOUT WHAT YOU
WANT, ADAM SCHIFF OBVIOUSLY
SEEMS TO HAVE IMPEACHMENT ON HIS
MIND.
YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT PROCESS.
TRUE PROCESS MAKES YOU GO LOOK
AT THE FACTS AND THEN HE
DETERMINE SOMETHING.
WE DID THIS UNDER CLINTON,
NIXON.
THEY PUT OUT EIGHT PAGES OF HOW
THEY WANT TO HANDLE THIS.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW HOW THEY
WILL TRY TO TAKE THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS AND GET THEM THROUGH
THE COMMITTEE.
WE DON'T HAVE A TIME FRAME.
WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT HOW
WE ARE ACTUALLY TO VIEW THOSE
AND WHEN THEY GOT TO OUR
COMMITTEE, HOW THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS TEAM LOVE HEARINGS.
THERE IS NO PROCESS AND THERE TO
SAY YES, THE COMMITTEE WILL HAVE
AN OPEN HEARING.
ARE WE GOING TO BE BOUND TO THE
REPORT THAT ADAM SCHIFF GIVES
US?
IF WE ARE THAN ADAM SCHIFF
BETTER BE THERE TO TESTIFY.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY WANT YOU TO
APPEAR THAT THEY HAVE DONE
SOMETHING, IN REALITY ALL THEY
DID WAS SOLIDIFY ADAM SCHIFF'S
CONTROL.
THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, THEY
KICKED THEM AND FOREIGN AFFAIRS
OUT.
THEY TIGHTENED IT DOWN FURTHER.
FOR THEM TO TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
GOOD.
I CHALLENGE THEM, LET'S HAVE AN
HONEST DEBATE.
IF YOU WANT THIS TO BE A TRUE
INQUIRY THAN TREAT TREATED WITH
RESPECT AND THE DEFERENCE THAT
IT DESERVES, NOT THE WAY THEY'RE
DOING IT NOW IN THE BASEMENT OF
THE CAPITAL.
>> Bret: HERE'S CONGRESSMAN
CLYBURN AND SPEAKER PELOSI TODA
TODAY.
>> THE HEART OF THE CONFLICT,
THE MORE GLORIOUS THE TRIAL.
WE ARE HERE TODAY BECAUSE BRAVE,
DEDICATED, PUBLIC SERVANTS AND
PATRIOTS ARE STANDING UP FOR
THEIR COUNTRY.
>> NOBODY, I DOUBT ANYBODY IN
THIS PLACE OR ANYBODY THAT YOU
KNOW COMES TO CONGRESS TO TAKE
THE OATH OF OFFICE, COMES TO
CONGRESS TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
UNLESS HIS ACTIONS ARE
JEOPARDIZING OUR HONORING OUR
OATH OF OFFICE.
>> Bret: I UNDERSTAND
CONGRESSMAN YOUR ARGUMENTS ABOUT
PROCESS UNDER ARGUMENTS ABOUT
FAIRNESS.
THEY ON THE FLOOR NUMEROUS TIMES
TALKED ABOUT THE SUBSTANCE OF
CONCERNS OF MEN LIKE THE
COLONEL, OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED ABOUT THIS CALL AND
WHAT THEY SAW BEHIND THE SCENES.
ON THE SUBSTANCE QUESTION, DO
YOU HAVE CONCERNS AT ALL?
>> NO, NOT AT THIS POINT.
SHE SAID THEY DIDN'T COME TO
CONGRESS TO IMPEACH.
DID WE DON'T HAVE A HUGE
CONTROVERSY THE DAY OF SWEARING
IN FROM A CONGRESSWOMAN FROM
MICHIGAN WHO SAID THAT WE ARE
HERE TO IMPEACH HIM?
I MEAN COME ON.
YOU KNOW BETTER THAN THIS.
YOU'RE PANDERING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHEN YOU SAY THAT.
ON THE SUBSTANCE ISSUE, WE CAN
TALK ABOUT PROCESS WHICH WE GET
THIS OUT OF THE OPEN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SUBSTANCE.
WE SEE THE TRANSCRIPT AND WE
KNOW WHAT'S IN THE TRANSCRIPT
AND WE SEE WHAT IS THERE.
WE KNOW FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NEITHER HAVE SAID THERE WAS ANY
PRESSURE.
THERE WAS NOTHING FROM HIS SIDE
THAT CALLS I'M CONCERNED.
WE ALSO KNOW FOR A FACT THAT THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT DID NOT
EVEN KNOW THESE DISCUSSIONS WERE
GOING ON UNTIL LATE AUGUST AT
THE EARLIEST OF THIS CALL TOOK
PLACE ON JULY 25TH.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT BILL TAYLOR,
ONE OF THEIR STAR WITNESS HAS
ONE NOT ON FIRST-HAND
INFORMATION, NOT EVEN
SECONDHAND, HE'S IN FOURTH HAND
INFORMATION.
IF WE GO FORWARD WE WILL
DEFINITELY HIT THE PROCESS --
PROBLEMS, BUT WILL ALSO HAVE THE
SUBSTANCE.
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN LAID OUT.
NOTHING THE PRESIDENT DID WRONG,
IT'S WHAT WE DID FOR TEN MONTHS
IN THE COMMITTEE WHILE WE WERE
SAYING HE WAS A RUSSIAN AGENT.
LET'S LET THE PEOPLE TAKE A DEEP